boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still in the Boston metro area I'm
really excited to be talking about all
things related to probabilities Bayesian
reasoning applying that to things like
the justice system the medical system
engineering and project management and
execution we have the absolute privilege
of sitting down with dr. Mary Kanter
hello hello hey hey Allen thanks for
coming on to the show thanks well thanks
for inviting me to your show you the
real privilege to talk to you thank you
and thanks to our friend Steve wait for
introducing us yes you shout out yes and
it's so cool how you've been teaching me
in just a short span of like an hour
just why exactly probabilities are so
serious in our world and why they matter
so much and he did the PhD in math at
Berkeley and then you've been working
over the last 20 years you did work with
IBM the last 10 years you've been doing
work with applying probabilities to
actual execution flows and project
management flows and now most recently
the the CTO and the co-founder of app
tidge and which is actually bringing
this forth as an entrepreneurial system
for people to actually be able to use
and apply and make their workflows much
better so off also author two books
along the way there's a lot of amazing
work that you've done along the way and
I'm excited to unpack that in the end
and explain to other people why exactly
this is so important so let's start with
your interest in mathematics because
math is kind of like the code of the
universe okay where does why did you
have to get picked up with it why do you
fall in love with it well it's it's
interesting I mean I was always really
math for me was like my easiest topic
way back to junior high or something
okay so I always just assumed that
that's that I would be a mathematician
and it it I it's more than that it's
easy is that it really gives you a kind
of it's both empowering and and gives
you insights to what's really going on
around you yes and and and and in a way
that is just so the words I that's how
uses empowering but I just love to know
how things work I sort of get behind
magic tricks I get behind how systems
really work together and the language
for all of that is mathematics yeah
right so gives you the foundation for
understanding the universe really really
well yes never I do it and then I
discovered over the years that there's
lots of opportunity to apply these
things to lots of really important real
world problems and so what I discovered
sort of after I got my PhD is I really
didn't want to be an academic
mathematician so I gotten that far just
heard about co-state right and then I
realized I didn't that would that was
fun to know about but I wasn't really
turned on by the purity of mathematics I
was really turned on by how this really
affected real-world things so I sort of
retooled myself as an applied
mathematician and I've been just sort of
applying that in a whole bunch of
different domains ever since so I have
papers and physics journals and papers
and geophysics journals I have papers
and engineering journals now I'm working
on applying AI methods for sports
performance and the fact is just
wonderful bit of plate and all these
different domains and of course app
tidge and helping people get better in
project management yep you know so this
is so important because you're actually
translating the mathematics into applied
again applying the mathematics into
real-world scenarios that are in many
ways either a click accelerator augment
formants yes and they also do things
like potentially eradicate errors that
occur and this is these are both crucial
right and so yeah teach us about that
well the world is getting real
complicated perhaps you've noticed yeah
and there's a fear among some of us that
the we're building systems that are too
complicated for us to manage and I think
you know and and so if we're going to
get our arms around that we have to
understand the likelihood of events of
what would happen if we do this what
would have happened if we didn't do that
that's what Judea pearl in his book of Y
talks about intervention and
counterfactuals and we live in really
wondrous times where we have the math to
do this and we have the tools online and
various mathematics and power on the
cloud that we actually can apply these
mathematics to do things so I tell my
friends it's a wondrous time to be a
mathematician right now we have we have
this real strong need to work with these
complicated systems think about how hard
it is to make medical decisions like
your friend Ian who has who's trying to
make the right decision in a in an
intensive care unit for possible most
likely terminal patients how do you make
the right decision you need real
frameworks to do this we have those
tools people aren't using them it's and
the same kind of thing with building
complex the prod the kind of things
we're building are highly integrated and
highly complex the teams that build them
are highly integrated highly complex how
do we know how they're gonna perform
well we don't but we can we can make we
could do the but we can start looking at
the probabilities of how they might
perform and what's the most likely
outcomes and again we should be applying
these tools because we have this problem
when we have the you know need meets
opportunity it's so cool that you
indicated that as we've evolved we've
moved towards complexity
yeah and how humans find themselves as
stewards of this rock and
earth and now we have to figure out okay
we're building these extremely complex
systems and yet humans are we're don't
we're not necessarily building the
knowledge foundations to know how to
manage these complex systems yes exactly
so it's so but we have to move yours we
have no choice
yes all right so that's what's that's
the underlying motivation of all this
real I love it I love it and then we
started hinting towards you you started
hinting towards okay there's there's
there's there's aspects to this in in
athletics or in judicial or in medical
or project management and execution of
engineering and design tasks within
companies so you know so any in your in
your career as you as you slowly started
getting to AB ditch tell us about that
kind of that kind of twenty-year chunk
of time when you were like okay I'm
applying this these are the and these
are the key areas that I want to see
this applied as soon as possible and
then how did you start yeah so my main
journey is through project management
okay and for reasons that are you know
you know there's you want to get into
too much history because then they don't
take up the whole time I'm old enough
that the stories take forever but no but
I I was working on the graphics I was
working in IBM on the wrist system 6000
which was IBM's answer to the UNIX
workstations based on reduced
instruction set technology and so we
were building a new hardware
architecture a new version of UNIX AIX
3.0 and a whole new graphics I was on
the graphics subsystem part a whole new
set of graphics adapters whole new api's
and we had to get this thing out the
door in a certain amount of time okay
ridiculous you need to think about on
the face of it who would do this right
and we did it okay and it came in a year
late but that's not good in the whole
history of that and what I realized was
that
the ability of people to manage these
countries we were being asked by our
project men by our stakeholders when
would we be done with this effort I had
literally four graphics adapters three
new api's on an unstable operating
system and they were asking me when we
are gonna be done and the answer is I
don't know right so I made up a date and
everybody was making updates another
plane that I would call management
chicken which I was betting this guy was
going to turn himself in before I was
but I have to okay oh we would have been
on time if yeah yeah right or because
he's late tickets all the blame no one
notices that I'm late so I didn't really
hit me I was in my I was in my managers
office and he puts up the Gantt chart in
my tasks and I'm posed to have I have on
some nine month tasks in all this
building out the new you know device
driver for this new thing and he says
according to this you're 48 percent done
aren't you and I said I had a choice and
I said I could say no and he they're not
again to a whole bunch of questions as
why not I had no idea so I said yes and
everybody else said yes and then the
surprise came later right so I say so I
said when I became to realize is that I
was being asked a ridiculous question
that really mattered to the business
okay that and the sort of adversarial
relationship that project managers get
into with their management where the
management asks them a ridiculous
question and the and what happened with
the agile manifesto I think one way to
look at it was that the developer said
we're not gonna do this anymore you know
it's it's it's ridiculous to do this and
somebody would take it to an extreme
saying you're gonna get it when you get
it you can't run a business that way
either this is when the math started
kicking in I said and I started
realizing that the time to complete a
project like this there's no such thing
oh and this is the other thing
if I gave them a prediction a prediction
of when I was going to be done I was
measured whether I was going to be
whether that number turned out to be
right or wrong yeah right so I started
leading up actually one of the things I
did in IBM its are leading a interest
group in project management and I gave a
talk at one of the cuff at one meeting
where of actually actually Grady boots
who was a great developer of object
methods was sick and so they asked me to
come in
so I played Grady at the conference and
I gave a talk on embracing uncertainty
and my main idea was that the time to
complete isn't a known quantity it's a
probability distribution and what we
call random variable and the best thing
rather than get into a fight I went and
so you don't there's no one number which
is right there's just a probability of
things that might happen and and so the
right question is do we understand the
shape of this distribution and should we
manage it together as the management and
the thing and the room got real
interesting about a third of the room
thought I was nuts and a third of the
room got sick and in third of the room
didn't understand me and if the room
said oh my god thank God someone's been
saying yeah it's about time yeah okay
which and so I've been building out
those techniques ever since then which
is essentially this lets you and I
management agree that this is the likely
set of outcomes this is the time to
complete is a random variable let's look
at its distribution and oh by the way
let's manage that together because we
can affect the odds it's not true
gambling we can change the odds by
working together yep okay so that and
there's a good example of where you go
and say ask an engineer or manager of
Engineers hey look we have this project
that we'd like to get done how long is
he gonna take to get done well I have no
idea
well I was gonna take three years no
who's gonna take one year no can you get
it done in six months yeah we could
barely get yeah six months would be the
we know worst case scenario so what
would be the best case scenario oh well
maybe two months well then that already
brings it to a
more of a period of certainty and then
assigning probabilities to it looks like
probably four or five months would be a
pretty safe bet what we actually do this
is is triangular distributions where we
where we look at and what do you think
is the most likely thing and we build a
distribution where it's no probability
below the lowest no probability above
the highest and the highest then we sort
of slope up to the max and yeah by the
way this is a technique that's been
widely talked about by Douglas Hubbard
in his book how to measure or anything
you know so the other thing that's
interesting is all these ideas are out
there it's just a matter putting them
together yeah it really is into the
systems of complexity to make them yeah
certain that's right
and so each task has a product has a as
a profit has a triangular distribution
associated with it
now tasks have dependencies and they go
in parallel and all that so computing
the joint probability of the time to
complete given all those things well
that's hard there been tools to do this
for a while using Monte Carlo simulation
but they're they're hardly they've been
hard to use one of the things that that
but this is getting us started but the
other thing that that I realized was
that the team completion rate or
velocity is also not a number that we
can know it is a probability
distribution again it's a random
variable and particularly for things
where our novel projects where it's not
like melding light bulbs where you can
get to a steady state you never get to a
steady state right what does it mean to
best have a steady workflow from finding
requirements you know if I spend say if
I spend five guys working at a certain
rate to paint a wall I can predict when
the wall get painted I have five guys
working on requirements how do I know
how long that's going to take right and
adding a sixth person they slow it down
as Fred Brooks is pointed out yeah right
so I can apply those sorts of
mathematics it's playing the wrong math
again it's all about the math yeah but
there is a probability distribution that
you can learn about rape about rape too
completion so now I have to learn that
probability distribution and I have to
include that with the various sizings
and roll that up and and now now the
math gets complicated cuz I'm to use
Bayesian parameter learning techniques
and whatever that's what led to app did
finally yeah and so we do all that and
the whole trick now is to make that real
consumable and what we have found is
that teams really adopt this nicely
because we're just using rather than
throwing away information that they
already have because they know they have
known unknowns let's capture the known
unknowns and use that rather than
throwing it away
yeah and you know rather than arguing
everybody into a single number let's not
even bother let's take the known
unknowns capture that it's part of what
the project notes and all that rolls up
and the point is that this is this this
is this is an example for project
management that we're doing but the same
kind of reasoning that time that the
likelihood of an intervention working
for a drug or the likelihood that you
really are drunk if you test positive on
a test all these things are random
variables yes all these things are
probabilities and as a society we should
get to a point we understand them and
use them properly yes right yes this way
where you're just where you're going
there I would really want to get to
these examples for everyone the examples
are so so important because they were
super applicable to our lives and then
also I want to make sure as you were
talking about things like a the
triangular distribution and you're
talking about how in something like a
rate of velocity of a team being able to
perform and you see that they oh they
hit the four five month mark they're
getting faster and faster and more
effective at completing tasks and then
also the new or you mentioned this to me
earlier as well the adversarial
component is gone more so because you're
right the there's not as much of a
of tension going on between up between
nodes in a hierarchy and in a company
yeah there was also another thing which
was the I think this is so crucial when
when you when you figure out that you
have your give your engineering team
potential he's given a task and the task
is to get this done and you initially go
for the lowest hanging fruit first that
that is going to bite you in the butt
later because it looks like you're on on
map on on rate are you're gonna get
there and then at the end you're doing
the hardest things and you miss your
deadline because you're doing the
hardest things at the Agra so let's talk
about that so there's a classical
project management there's something
called earned value okay and the
question is how much of the work have
you done with the dollars you've spent
okay and the idea is is to claim where
value for work that's completed okay so
and there's still this is still very
strong and there's various teams that I
have what would they call the earned
value please switch manner in which
which which look at your projects the
trouble with that is it you know people
people behave by trying to optimize the
measures that they're measured by okay
so that's why tax policy used to at
least encourage homeownership by
lowering tap the thing or if you you
tell a better example you tell policemen
that they're gonna be measured by how
many tickets they write they're gonna
write a bunch of tickets yeah whether or
not they they should have written a
bunch of tickets they're just gonna
write a bunch of tickets yeah and then
if there's lobbyists involved in medical
processes and then there's gonna be more
of those medical processes but how many
of them were actually necessary goes out
alone oh right yeah there's a whole
bunch of stuff about people being
rewarded for prescribing drugs yes for
example okay so earn value was so the
project manager saying well I'm going to
get rewarded by doing the
easy task because the liking claimer
value okay because there you go what I
noticed was and others that real
progress in project management I have
this novel risky project a lot of
uncertainty
I shouldn't be measuring progress on
whether I've done the easy stuff I
should be measuring progress by whether
I've reduced the uncertainty mm-hm
right cuz good cuz the way it is the day
I started I have a whole bunch of
uncertainty if I'm gonna ship tomorrow I
better not have much uncertainty yes and
so you wonder what you're doing is
you're asking people to tackle the
hardest things at the start right as
best as they can that way they maximize
the certainty right they Louvre the
uncertainty over time rather than just
completing tasks yes correct
because that because that's how I know
you're gonna ship right and that's not
earned value in fact there are ways you
could assign a value to reducing
uncertainty and everybody would win you
know whatever and so one of the other
things we did in a pitch is actually
show a graph while seeing how the
uncertainty is being managed and whether
it's going up and down okay
because what we're trying to get
everybody to collaborate on oh by the
way it's not just the manager with their
management it's also the managers with
their staff 360 kind of thing is that we
should all collaborate on removing the
uncertainties in our project so that we
can make the goals that the project has
now sometimes these goals are time-based
and sometimes other things but we should
know again if if I have committed to
ship tomorrow I better know for sure
that I'm going to be able to ship
tomorrow
there should be no residual uncertainty
in my project right now if I'm four
weeks out and there's a whole bunch of
uncertainty which can happen from your
scenario of the lowest hanging fruit
it's exactly what happens they push the
uncertainty to the end of the project
where they have less time to deal with
it
so there's an old saying in project
management which is ninety percent of
the project is spent ninety percent of
the project is spent with 90 percent of
the year in value
cleaned okay
and this is why we what's cool about
math now we know why that is because it
didn't work on the uncertainty they they
worked on on claiming the they did the
earlier they did exactly what you
shouldn't do which is is if you increase
the uncertainty by putting it off to the
end of the project yeah so not only are
you increasing certainty for the teams
of project managers and engineers and
companies that really want and now have
to just being used by companies and
they're actually seeing great benefits
by using the service and I'm totally
seeing lots more companies catching on
to this oh we can have more certainty in
what we're building we can have more
certainty in our timelines more
certainty in our teams so then there's
also this sort of it's it's important to
identify that the probabilities within
within how to actually calculate and
synthesize all of the probabilities
because there's so many variables that
go into this and becomes difficult to
actually figure out where the the where
the where the signal ends up being in
you know you started giving these
examples of when you're when there's a
where people are getting bate paid based
on the amount of tickets they give out
or based on the amount of
pharmaceuticals they give out and so
then that's creating these unjust
systems right in medicine and injustice
and so this becomes this becomes a
problem and so we can potentially amend
that problem yes yes and there's an
important point you make which is
there's two ways to deal with
uncertainty and make one way is to have
don't do interesting things boring know
what sir so what are the things that
happens if you insist this happens
though if you insist that I have to make
a date I'm not going to take any risks
mm-hmm right and I'm gonna move out all
the risky interesting which there's a
risk reward thing here yeah we could do
and and and part of what's going on in
our
system is the lifespan of our companies
is shorter than it used to be right and
so you know or it because there's more
disruption going on so they have to take
on novel projects abroad so it's not
necessarily so you don't necessarily
want to reduce the initial uncertainty
you want to have methods for dealing
with it yep
I've seen company I've seen prior I've
seen companies who because of this thing
I you know of rewarding this is another
false reward thing if you reward project
managers for hitting the date every time
with the original content at the
original budget what you're going to see
is for more and more boring projects
less and less riskless less interesting
stuff so they actually move that they
actually manage the value out of their
development organization and in order to
stay relevant you have to take big risks
got risks and risks alright so you have
to know how to manage those rather than
avoid them and this is what I used to
call embracing uncertainty right let's
not let's not be afraid of it let's
embrace it make it an opportunity but
you need the tools to do that and that's
where the problem and if you treat
uncertainty as the a risk announced risk
as the uncertainty in meeting a measure
that matters to the business then the
way you assume risk is by understanding
that uncertainty and working it off yes
and that's what the tools do and we had
this with this really good example where
if you are building up the collective
learning of civilization on top of let's
say scientific literature and we're
building it up and we're building it up
and something that's that was discovered
just a couple years ago is Higgs boson
and if you're trying to add something
like his biggs boson to our
understanding of physics and put that
into the knowledge foundation of
civilization you have to be extremely
certain that that is correct and you
have to have a very very low probability
of
we were wrong about that versus with
medical literature it seems as though
you can you were okay no problem one out
of every 20 times it's no no problem
that that's wrong that butterfly effects
and cascades out and ends up causing a
lot of harm because we are letting
uncertainties creep into the foundation
of what we're trying to build up as
knowledge all right so the way to issues
here - two things talked about here one
is sort of the standard so a lot of us
call ourselves identify as being basins
that's a thing to be what Bayesian
believe is Sean Carroll talks all really
nicely about this and his latest book
the big the big picture which is we
believe in things for which we have
evidence yes okay and we don't think
anything is a hundred percent true the
stronger the evidence the more we
believe in it and so the Higgs boson is
the example is and I actually look this
up so what so they get more and more
evidence at the end they had found the
Higgs boson they saw a signal then they
saw another signal then they saw another
signal and they started looking what is
the joint probability of seeing all
these signals and at what point did they
decide to they were ready to declare
yeah and it turned out that I don't
remember the exact number but it was
something like 1 in 10 billion yeah so
it's not 100% but it's it's a really
good bet yeah okay now in the medical
literature as you point out people will
publish as as oh if the chance of them
being wrong is you know they Pete this
significance of 0.05 that means that
there's only a 5% chance that this
happened by chance by chance yep
but that means that one out of 20
articles just happened by chance
and then the medical literature is
there's a whole lot of writing about
this and then the stuff that the then
there's no one ever gets paid to find to
actually do the experiment again again
and so then we get into a lot of in
unreproducible effects and and so it's
really hard now the literature is
getting better because people are
getting smarter about this
yeah yeah and whatever but it's and
shout-out to our friends Peter and
Lindsey and and Helen for doing the hoax
papers because start that's now starting
to to to point out how we can't be
letting the the improper scientific
evidence enter in the foundation that
we're trying to build up on yeah right
but the point out that what all this is
that there's nothing 100% certain so
what things so what we need to do is be
certain enough to make the right
decisions most of the time right or to
make the right decisions in a way that
is beneficial to a system is
economically makes sense whatever
so I one of the things exercises I'm
working with the team where we're
looking at sustainability of new system
new systems and their impact on the
sustainability of the oceans yeah okay
now you know so they're gonna build a
fish farm and they're going to do this
okay no we can't be a hundred percent
sure this is gonna be better than
another model but we can build a
bayesian that kind of model to find out
what is the what is the likelihood of
this improving things and then we can
look at the investment and decide of
that same kind of same kind of
investment and so they're investors in
the world who care about this they want
to invest in things that both make money
and improve the environment yes
but they need again this kind of
Bayesian reasoning for that for that to
work we live in really wonderful times
on that we have as I said there's judea
pearls book on the book of why but
there's a whole lot of mathematics
behind that he has a book on causality
and then there's Fenton and Neal's book
on Bayesian Nets and their tools and so
we have the methods it's just a matter
but these are as was kind of and say
these are thinking slow kind of systems
yes but we need to be applying them
yeah that's absolutely the point and in
the more that I think that we think slow
collectively geopolitically as a planet
though the less whoops moments we'll
have and we don't really have room for
oops moments anymore we just had max
tegmark on this show from future life
Institute and you when you had an oops
moment with with you know the seat belt
or the airbag with vehicles that's fine
I mean couple maybe hundred thousands of
people died before that okay that's okay
but a nuclear weapon a mutually assured
destruction nukes moment a malevolent
artificial general intelligence oops
moment no we could wipe out it's an
existential crisis so when when we point
out the sort of there oh yeah this this
like this the probabilities that that
that you can actually show as you as you
go and and and build them out inside of
computer models mm-hm
is so gorgeous because you're able to
tweak the different variables like a a
blood alcohol a measure measurement
device of breath element right that you
can't rely on it a hundred percent of
the time and the same things true about
something that's trying to find some
sort of a medical ailment or something
and so because of that you end up
getting a certain amount of false
positives mm-hmm and then now you can
actually model that as a probability you
can also add another variable like age
like sex like potentially what type of
car they're driving with their
socioeconomic status is all different
types of religion etc and then that
those variables we can actually get
closer to certainties in understanding
these things and then we need to make
better tools that are also less
uncertain right so the point here is if
you just give person a without any other
information in a give person a DWI test
and they test positive that doesn't mean
they're drugged first of all that
doesn't mean they're driving under the
influence because if you drive under the
influence you're mostly you're very
likely as positive with the test
but that doesn't mean if you test
positive you will actually are driving
under the influence
now those not and it turns out it's
remarkable how we would like a five
percent false positive kind of number
which it's or where these tests tend to
be and there's only one chance in a
thousand or one chance and a hundred
that a person is actually drunk anyhow
this would be going down a row of a
hundred people and Riley maybe five of
them are actually drunk and you try and
see out of the ninety five people that
aren't drunk how many of them would get
fall flat falsely flagged yeah and it
turns out that the percent of people who
who are would test positive but aren't
drunk is remarkably high like twenty
percent in the most of these things okay
no but on the other hand if they're
driving a red sports car and they're
eighteen years old
you can sort of schönau the
probabilities two-thirds higher yeah now
in in reality now also if they're drunk
you know now so if you're only relying
on the test scene just stopping people
around and just relying on the tests
they actually through that there was a
whole bunch of cases actually throughout
the state of Texas because that's what
they were doing now if a person's
driving erratically and you give them
the test now that's different but that
wasn't what was happening so
understanding the difference between if
you test positive and that if you're
drunk then you're going to test positive
the probability of that is different
than if you test positive then you're
drunk now that's true for by the way a
lot of medical tests if you test
positive for this disease if you know
the disease you're very likely to test
positive if you if the disease is rare
and you test positive it's not all that
likely you have the disease and what the
doctor is supposed to say is I'd like to
give you a different kind of test
okay so there's another thought that I
incur to me about why Bayesian reasoning
is really
important the way Bayesian things work
if you start out with some prior belief
and you adjust that belief with the
evidence now it turns out that you for a
lot of things whenever your prior belief
was if there's enough evidence it
doesn't matter you get to the right
thing and I can show you examples of
that if you have if you a hundred
percent believe in something no amount
of evidence is going to change you okay
which is why it's so important to leave
area in your ideology open have openness
that way when you someone is potentially
adding to your perspective to help you
see the world in a more true or way that
you're receptive right change it and I
think Thomas Bayes 300 years ago
actually wrote about this this is a very
old insight yeah okay now let's look at
some of the climate change discussion
there are people who no amount of
evidence will let them believe well they
are so convinced hundred percent
convinced that man isn't changing the
climate that no amount of evidence will
change their rides the other thing is so
part of what is important for us as a
society is to understand that there's
all but never be a hundred percent sure
of anything and always look at the
evidence so that you can update your
beliefs yes this is so important okay
always be looking at learning or
evidence adding more evidence to the
equation to change your ability to
change your beliefs that it's almost as
it's a steering processing process and
if the ones that are willing to to learn
from more evidence and they steer they
could steer into more truthful
directions right yeah and and the math
will take you there math will take you
there
so what's so it sort of rather sum to
the beginning thing we talked about what
why mathematics see so this little
theorem about Bayes theorem which says
that that what you do is you start out
with some belief and then you update
that belief based on evidence
and that if you have a hundred percent
certain in something no amount of
evidence will change that is actually a
way to understand some of the social
behavior we're seeing that's right and
some of the conversations that's right
right and why you know you can you can
expand that to gun control and whatever
your abortion although one policy in the
it's because we're that we got trapped
in a binary thought process that and I'm
a hundred percent in my ideology right
and so no evidence can change that
that's what the math will tell you it's
so cool so we can actually bring a
mathematics lens to our discourse yes
most one another and so minimally what
we can do is have a a percentage of
openness yes on ideologies that way
we're leave an ability to stay open or
like I like to do and I like to merge
people to do is to stay free thinking
stay independent and that way when will
you see people that are just watching
Fox News or just watching CNN and they
have blind spots then you got to watch
both and you have to learn from other
people that actually live you know in
different parts of the world and give
first-hand information yourself I like
taking a math perspective on it binary
thinking is 100% on your ideology but
the gray area of the nuance is having
50/50 or 60/40 and even a TTIP 8020
ninety ten it just needs some amount of
willingness to learn from the evidence
and see where it takes you yeah you know
so I'm 90% sure of this but if you can
show me some evidence I'm willing to
change boom right here yes that's it
yeah so this kind of thinking is just
so-so in project management we need to
learn from the evidence of how the team
is performing in America you know in the
medical things we got to apply Bayesian
reasoning and to understand the
probability of what various
interventions would do
properly right and then in looking at
things around us as we learn together
society we have to learn from the
evidence that we see that's to build the
most just systems that enable the best
flourishing right into us tool to come
to correct conclusions and make make
good decisions Murray this is so
fascinating that you're working on
applying the mathematics and applying
these probability measurements into
maximizing the efficacy of of these
different systems the metal advisory
projects yeah yeah I love it so Murray
tell us about where you see all of this
going because it's gonna be applied into
all of these different industries we're
gonna basically put on a math lens as we
enter into probabilities make it more
certainty well yeah I don't know but
I'll tell you I'll just sort of Lee I'm
just something I'm just seeing now okay
what do I book yeah I have some belief
in this okay because I have I try to
actually live in now we just talk about
being up easier so some evidence I'm
saying yeah okay Judea pearls book The
Book of Y is actually number one in its
category on Amazon hmm okay I'm having
all my friends read it and they all come
back to me and say wow yeah right
it asks really thought-provoking
questions right yeah okay the the you
see articles more and more there was a
recent article in The Wall Street
Journal by madoski Berger talking about
the same kind of thing so people are
beginning that what we so it's beginning
to permeate at least some level of the
more general population these techniques
go back to you know I don't know what
they started but you know it really can
be traced back for 300 years but judea's
pearl
work on Bayesian net and then Fenton and
Niels and Gianna risk - and there's the
Bayesian labs you know risk tools so we
have so I what we're seeing now is it's
it's sort of coming out of the it's
moving down in in sort of the
intellectual planes to more and more
thinking and because we have the tools
to do this we have the compute power of
the web like Aptus could not have
existed if it weren't for the cloud it
just couldn't have okay
the tools that I built it in our Python
modules and things that make the
programming efficient so we can people
can build other tools so the technology
is here and people are beginning to
think about the next gen of AI being
more about can I read an image better or
play chess better or play go better but
can I start making better decisions
about interventions yeah right but that
is gonna be the next generation of AI
we're training it on narrow systems now
to also make it now making it more
general on yeah better decision making
for human-oriented yes exactly yeah so
that's good that I already see that
beginning to happen love it that so
that's that who knows where that's gonna
go but it's already it's already
beginning to happen because humans are
so irrational at times and we we do
think ya thank ya thank ya you know we
we are we we have a lot of emotion we
have a lot of sleep deprivation we have
a lot of addiction we have a lot of yeah
tendencies that we we don't even believe
that we actually do but admitting that
we do is the first step to this really
to solving it as a problem and letting
things like a non-biased exact
artificial
intelligence help make these decisions
let's not sleep deprived right so
notional so these systems will take over
our jobs but the they'll really help us
do these kind of jobs better and give us
a an objective non-biased you told me
the stuff that you believe about these
tasks and how we've looked at how these
teams have performed or Utah and the
other examples I've been looking at it's
been a cornerman you've told us this
data or this is data that you've
measured from population studies right
and now you have to decide whether or
not to administer this treatment or this
surgical approach that might kill
somebody should you do it yeah yeah you
know people are people are lousy at that
building a system that would know how to
at least give you the best answer yes
would be real helpful
it wouldn't replace the doctor it would
really help the dialogue with the doctor
right there's because Murray how can we
form this Bayesian network in our head
calculating dozens of variables see
where we allows it so there's the
classic example of the Monty Hall
problem do you know the Monty Hall
problem I don't think so
okay so the Monty Hall problem is is
you're based on let's make a deal right
so the deal is it's a standard problem
there are three doors okay okay you know
the three doors problem I think so yeah
continue okay so behind one door is a
car and between the other two doors is a
goat okay and the presumption is you
would rather have a door you'd rather
have a car than a goat I know some
people would rather have a goat in the
car but most people would rather have a
car let it go okay and so you open up
you choose a door and Monty how opens up
a different door and shows you behind
that door there's a goat and he says do
you want to stay with this door or do
you want to or do you want to switch
doors so now you have a 50/50 chance of
the car no you don't you don't that
see that's always the that's the
thinking fast that is the data contrast
and Paul Erdos got this wrong by the way
Paul Erdos got this right when this
Roberts politician when this was first
published by what Laurel wants the block
or whatever date was she got the answer
right and like one of these popular
magazines and a lot of people wrote in
and said she got it wrong including poet
okay so far you so he owned one goat and
you know juice which do you switch and
the answer is your chances are doubled
if you switch of getting a car now
almost no one can get this right in
their heads okay it's I think I started
getting a little taste a taste of it
that that the that that that the door
that you had selected was was a door
that potentially had the car behind it
and then you were shown that one of the
one of the doors that didn't have a car
yeah right and the question is should
you switch to the other door yeah
correct and you double your chances by
switching to the other door and almost
no one gets us right into Italy continue
now right okay so the do aunt I have my
explanation why that's true at least you
could by the way you could run you could
be a frequentist and run 100 experiments
you discovered that yeah or you could
just think it through continue okay so
the way you think it's really is the
chance of you being right was one and
three yes at the VA right okay so that
means there's a two and three chance
that it's one of the other two doors
yeah he showed you the so did that
change by the him opening a door yeah
no it's still two and three there was
one of the other two are still two or
three but now it's now you know and he
did you a favor by showing which of the
other two doors not to open you see yeah
so the point is you got a new piece of
information he opened a door that didn't
have a goat you know more than you did
before so you had a one a chance to your
being right
he opened the door you I don't what a
chance
being right and not only that you
actually know where the two or three
door is it's the one he didn't open oh
so that door has two and three chances
yeah why does the door that he didn't
open that I didn't select have a two and
three chance of being cuz it had because
he knew it had a goat that's the point
he didn't open one by random he opened
one he knew how to goat that's why this
works okay uh-huh
you see so the whole system so this is a
point that pro makes there's a whole
system here right the system is you
choose something he chooses a door based
on your choice it wasn't an independent
choice people think it's 50/50 is
because it's an indication that he
thinks that they think that he was
working independently but he's not he
made a choice based on what you chose
okay okay okay yeah how do we know that
he okay because that's the rules of the
game that's the rules game okay okay now
you could go into well is it gonna
follow through oh sure sure yeah but the
point is that that even that amount of
and by the way that solve these Bayesian
reasoning gets you that real fast I can
build you amazing that to chose to do
this that's cool okay that's cool yeah
yeah see that's what I'm talking about
yeah you think it makes gives us better
decisions it helps us with slowing down
to think right right so you and that's
exactly it we have these complicated
systems that behave like the Monty Hall
problem yeah and we have to understand
the probabilities of making decisions
based on that yeah so this is sort of
like a toy problem but it's not really
because it shows several things one is
that almost no one gets fast thinking
system works I've had real arguments
with philosophers I had to take them
through this very carefully okay yeah
okay
I have some questions okay so let's okay
okay because some questions on the way
out first question yes what would you
say is a central guiding principle of
your life as I said I am I tell people
I'm at the Bob Bayesian devout Bay Z I
learned from evidence I believe in
things for which I have evidence Yeah
right that's a very important yeah not
essentially that's the guiding principle
that's beautiful okay how about there
are others but that's of course okay how
about how about do you believe that
we're in a simulation Oh
all that stuff what do you think oh you
think this is a base reality yeah
there's there's wheels yeah yeah yeah
even though we're making simulations
right now yeah and I'll tell you why you
know I actually have follow a little
about this okay cuz who have this
simulation is so so for example you lose
your keys five days later you find your
keys and then you remember that's where
you left it simulations are real good
right it's remarkably consistent right
the world we live in
it's so consistent I don't believe it
could be a simulation anymore really
no it's a silly you don't need it either
but it's also really amazed at how
there's no that things are always
entirely consistent there's no glitches
in the simulation ever well sometimes it
feels like deja vu is a glitch yeah well
yeah but that's something else we can
talk we can talk about how about what is
something that you believe to be true
that almost no one else believes to be
true oh I don't know if there's anything
like that now I don't think there is
anything like that how about what is the
deepest emotion you've ever felt Oh God
oh well I don't know I mean I don't know
if I can talk about that I mean I get
what's interesting I think I've been
with this I'm very rational about stuff
but I do respond very strongly
emotionally to things yeah you know what
and I'm actually believed by something
very empathetic yeah so like watching
some of the things that are going on we
like at the border I get really angry
yeah for example I don't know that's the
deepest emotion I've ever felt
yeah but I don't want what couldn't you
talk about it like why did it come up
that you didn't well I really mean
there's not a deepest demo this is not
aid be one of your deepest emotion yeah
yeah right well they're all very
standard
I mean you deeply love with my wife of
just these children but right now I'm
just so alone with my grandchildren yeah
yeah that that's very deep it is yeah I
mean and love them to death and quick
cuz they're still dead eh yeah yeah
right but I but really all of them yeah
and deep love for family yeah it's like
that Marie how about last question okay
what do you think the most beautiful
thing in the world you know this is you
can't not be syrupy so you know or soupy
about this but the fact the see the
thing is you know I really believe that
we're a small speck in the big universe
and the universe galaxies song and all
that right Eric I know all that stuff
but you know the fact
that we attack them that we really
develop emotional attachments for each
other that that we have empathy and we
can really emotionally connect I think
is remarkable it's really that you know
you know yeah it is this sir
you know we evolved I understand how
that evolves and all that but you love
and and emotional connection is a
remarkable thing it's it's still a great
mystery we'll learn more about it as we
learn more about consciousness and stuff
we're learning more about it now doesn't
make it less beautiful yeah this uh as
you say that it reminds me of when you
look at someone's eyes how crazy is it
that you can aim to try and understand
the last 20 50 70 years of their life
yeah that led them to the point where
they're at right yeah yeah yeah you know
in the con and you know you can what
without with or without a religious
thing our consciousness doesn't it's
things that blend right and that's what
that's a wonderful thing Marie this has
been so enlightening well thank you I've
learned so much I hope we all have taken
away the thank you so much you so much
they're the opportunity the importance
of probabilities the importance of
applying mathematics into our lives
across all different domains justice
medicine projects mm-hmm this is so
important to do in artificial
intelligence is helping this with that
mm-hmm the links in the bio for app did
you go check it out after com go and
check them out also give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you go ahead and see what
we can do with math and probabilities
and applying that into our world we'd
love to see you create and you build go
and manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love and we will see you
soon
thank you so much oh thanks bye bye bye
that's all she wrote okay
what fun